une matinée d'accueil aux allures de
rentrée ils sont plus de 300 avoir
décroché leur concours d'entrée maeva
cécile 23 ans est désormais professeur
stagiaire en svt ainsi prétendu c'est la
grande rentrée c'est un petit peu
nouveau cette année ça fait longtemps
qu'on attend ce moment là après le
concours mais c'est un peu l'inconnu
après la remise du livret d'accueil
place au traditionnel discours de
bienvenue avant de rentrer dans le vif
du sujet kohn jeu mes idées pour le
réseau codes de la photocopieuse accès
au réseau tenue en classe à l'insep et
le centre de formation des professeurs
on est très concret pour cette première
journée un jeune professeur partage son
expérience avec les stagiaires
la plus grosse difficulté celle envie de
faire des bons coups sur lesquels les
élèves ont accroché où ils vont pouvoir
acquérir les connaissances et les
compétences qu'on veut leur faire passer
et après avec l'habitude on se focalise
plutôt sur comment faire pour que
l'élève réussissez pas juif ou qu'ils
réussissent parce qu'on sait pas encore
trop comment ça durant cette année ses
stagiaires vont alterner formation à
l'insep et et cours dans un collège ou
lycée une pression évidente mais
visiblement pas pour pierre 27 ans qui a
travaillé deux années dans le privé
comme ingénieur avant de revenir à sa
première vocation
j'ai déjà fait du remplacement tant
qu'enseignant j'ai déjà eu fait des
stages de courte durée mais quand même
des stages c'était assez naturel pour
moi de me trouver devant la classe donc
non je pense pas que je serai soumis à
une certaine pression ça va pas me
déranger du tout son attitude face à la
classe c'est la question qui taraude la
plupart des stagiaires dont mail réussir
peut-être imposer son autorité
surtout quand on est jeune on vient de
sortir on n'a pas tout à fait terminée
nos études
donc on a une crédibilité aussi à
assurer auprès des élèves
mais c'est surtout de pouvoir tenir tout
un programme donné le meilleur de nous
mêmes pour répandre
pour tous ces choses sérieuses
commenceront lundi prochain pour la
rentrée et la rencontre avec leurs
élèves